[Música]
[Aplausos]
a liderança nas nossas empresas está
passando por um processo enorme de
transformação
a tecnologia ela tem impactado
diretamente nas nossas relações de
trabalho e principalmente nas relações
entre líderes e liderados por mais de 20
anos eu tive a oportunidade de estar à
frente de times talentosos na área de
tecnologia e hoje eu estou ao lado de
diferentes líderes e empreendedores
gestores que estão coordenando seus
times ea pergunta que mais escuto no meu
dia a dia é porque nossos melhores
profissionais estão embora das nossas
equipes
por outro lado quando eu converso com
esses profissionais e tenta entender por
que eles estão fazendo essas escolhas em
ainda às vezes escolhendo uma carreira
solo
eles me dizem eu não tinha espaço para
dar idéias
o meu trabalho não tinha significado
quando escuto isso pra mim soa como um
grande alerta um alerta que diz que nós
líderes estamos perdendo a capacidade de
gerir jeans talentosas
nós líderes estamos realmente falhando
algum tempo atrás eu estava liderando
uma equipe grande e vivia no mar um dia
a dia cheio de urgência cheio de de
trabalho né e sempre com senso de
urgência enorme para inovar
eu estava mergulhada em métodos e
processos em novas tecnologias e eu não
tinha mais tempo para as pessoas
eu não tinha mais tempo para aquilo que
realmente fazem a diferença
por exemplo eu não percebia que o meu
time estava desmotivado
eu não percebia que eles estavam
infelizes
o trabalho e eu não dava atenção por
baixo desempenho que eles tinham e
quando apareciam situações como essas
eu me blindava sabe e eu tentava
encontrar uma nova metodologia uma nova
forma de resolver aquilo dentro de algum
tipo de padrão era como se eu quisesse a
todo momento
a cada situação nova que encontrasse eu
encontrasse uma forma um script de
encaixar isso dentro do detalhe então
observe os números 60 por cento
uma pesquisa americana de mais de 1300
pessoas mostra para nós que mais de 60%
das equipes
elas não atingem os seus resultados e
apenas 14% das pessoas que estão conosco
nas nossas equipes
elas conhecem a estratégia da empresa
então quando eu olho nesses números e
entendia que o meu cenário era muito
parecido com aquele não conseguia
compreender que não bastava ter as
melhores tecnologias os melhores
profissionais e os melhores métodos
porque realmente o resultado não estava
dependendo disso e o que o convido vocês
a perceber que o que vai realmente fazer
a diferença e isso tudo é que nós
precisamos humanizar a liderança e para
isso eu trago aqui pra vocês três
práticas pelas quais nós vamos colocar o
ser humano em primeiro lugar nós vamos
colocar o ser humano em evidência antes
dos processos
a primeira prática é estabeleça contexto
e não controle estabelecer contexto
significa criar dentro do seu time um
código de como vocês agiram juntos a
forma de como vocês vão agir dentro de
um cenário de contingência
e dentro de um cenário de calmaria e
para isso a gente precisa entender o dna
da equipe
a gente precisa conhecer o que cada um é
muito bom e que sabe fazer muito bem é
insubstituível e no que cada um
realmente falha e que precisa de apoio e
aí e momentos de contingência a gente
cria um código de que nós agiremos
juntos e que nós conseguiremos resolver
os problemas e isso inclui o líder
também nesse cenário todo o líder ele é
uma peça do jogo
a segunda essa prática ela traz para nós
um elo de confiança entre líder e
liderado a segunda prática é crime
o empoderamento e massa criar
empoderamento é compartilhar processo
decisório com as pessoas é permitir que
elas tomem decisões mas para fazer isso
nós precisamos dar espaço para elas
nós precisamos dar a certeza que elas
podem tomar as decisões das idéias num
ambiente seguro e isso só acontece
quando nós líderes
começamos a diluir o nosso poder na
equipe e isso é muito difícil pra gente
então comece nas pequenas coisas
comece escolhendo projetos mais técnicos
a onde essas equipes elas podem ter mais
autonomia de tomar decisões
criem grupos compartilhados e nesses
grupos façam com que eles tomem as
decisões e se responsabilizem sobre seus
erros
essa prática ela faz com que a equipe
acredite que você realmente confia nela
e anos devolve pessoas felizes criativas
engajados e a terceira é decidida com
base em evidências
a gente está criando algo novo algo
inovador seja uma estratégia ou seja um
produto
a gente não consegue quantificar dados
para poder justificar
essa nova proposta então é muito comum
que a gente se perca em intermináveis
reuniões
a onde de um lado a gente tem alguém
tentando convencer o outro alguém de que
sua ideia melhor ea gente se perde nisso
então nós líderes nós temos que fazer o
que criar um sistema onde as pessoas
elas possam vir trazer as suas ideias
mans fazendo experimentos buscando
validar isso fora da empresa
então deixe sempre ruan que eles possam
se aproximar dos clientes e trazerem
para nós porque aquela ideia é válida e
crie uma rotina disso dentro da empresa
essa parte é muito boa porque ela traz
primeiro uma clareza ela reduz o stress
no dia a dia né
entre todo mundo e ela traz uma clareza
de como o processo decisório se dá
dentro da tua o teu time bom
nós todos sabemos que o futuro ele está
extremamente competitivo e cheio de
incertezas de complexidades
então eu convido vocês que não olhem
essas práticas e tentei encaixar as
pessoas dentro de um script que têm as
suas próprias práticas que se encorajem
e façam isso junto com seus times e que
em primeiro lugar
coloquem as pessoas antes dos processos
de em evidência para essas pessoas e
dêem a elas significado transparência e
volta
obrigada